I am Sophie she lacy joining me today is
a very special guest who you may have
seen on the for last week and you may
remember her from a throwback to Rebecca
Black thank you for being here thanks
for having me yeah so exciting so we
gotta talk about the for last week how
much fun did you have on that show what
a day that was the craziest day ever
because you know there's so much
anticipation and like excitement and
then nervousness and it was it was
really really fun and like this I mean
everything since then it's just been
even better it's been crazy
now of course Megan recognized you
immediately when you came out on stage
and that was one thing that like the
judges reactions I was like they could
have no idea anything about me they
could be like why watching her or what
but surely so you had no expectations of
whether they would know who you were or
not yeah
tell me about what Megan's words meant
to you oh my gosh I mean she has and
throughout this entire process just like
continually blowing my mind with how
sweet and encouraging because especially
with her like I look up to her as a
songwriter I look up to her as an artist
she's so involved with what she does
which I look up to you so much and so to
have her support me like it's crazy like
even talking about it I'm like it just
it almost does it makes sense to me it's
crazy to think that someone you look up
to can really just support you like that
would you ever do a song with Meghan
Trainor yes girl what cameras on Meghan
let's go let's do it that would be so
much fun are you kidding I love it it's
such an amazing songwriter she's
incredible are you guys still in touch
um she is very busy filming before yeah
yeah I mean it has been like the
greatest on social
and just like
[Music]